[Aplausos]
antes de cambiar el mundo tienes que
aceptar que tú también eres parte de él
esta es una frase de la película the
dreamers que cuentan la historia de
autodescubrimiento de tres jóvenes en la
francia del 68 pero hoy les voy a hablar
de francia ni de mayo del 68 de seguro
ya tendrán la oportunidad para aprender
sobre eso hoy yo les voy a hablar de
discapacidad y poder
pero seguramente se preguntarán por qué
una chica aparentemente normal les va a
hablar sobre esto y la razón por la que
yo decidí salir de mi zona de confort
para contarles mi historia es porque los
jóvenes no sabemos cómo y no nos
atrevemos a hablar de discapacidad
y bueno todo esto comenzó hace siete
años cuando mi vida era casi perfecta
era una de las chicas más populares del
colegio ganaba absolutamente todos los
concursos del cole tenía un montón de
amigos organizado a todas las fiestas
tenía todo lo que un chico de 15 años
pueda pedir
hasta que un día me detectaron lupus
eritematoso sistémico
esta es una enfermedad en la que todo tu
sistema inmunológico decide confundir a
tus órganos con bacterias o virus
atacando todo tu cuerpo es decir mi
cuerpo se estaba comiendo a sí mismo
justo un año después de esto cuando
tenía 16 años me estaban detectando otra
enfermedad pero tenía insuficiencia
renal crónica terminal lo que me decía
que mis riñones lo habían dejado de
funcionar por completo que tenía que
hacerme diálisis tres veces a la semana
y que había vez que he adquirido una
discapacidad severa física algo que
nunca pedí
cuando me dijeron esto todo el mundo que
había creado ya habían creado para mí se
derrumbó por completo pasar de ser una
de las chicas más importantes del
colegio a ser una chica para nada bonita
que no tenía amigos que no tenía cabello
y que no tenía nada de autoestima fue un
golpe muy duro
darte cuenta que todo lo que habías
construido de la nada desapareció y que
te iba a tocar vivir una nueva realidad
no es fácil
pero jamás pensé que en medio de todo
ese caos iba a surgir mi verdadero poder
y va a surgir mi verdadero yo
así que debía hacer algo y en todo buen
contacto en contra de todo buen consejo
de adulto decidí contarle al mundo que
yo tenía una discapacidad palabra que
está definida por la organización
mundial de la salud como una deficiencia
en tus capacidades físicas o mentales
que te impiden desarrollarse con
normalidad en la sociedad
que le digan esto a una niña de 16 años
que había sido rebelde por naturaleza
que la sociedad estaba condicionando mi
rol debido a que tenía una discapacidad
no era fácil yo tenía que hacer algo
para cambiar esta situación
así que un día decidí un papel y
un lápiz y hacer una lista de las cosas
que eran en las que no tenía que hacer
un viaje introspectivo y realmente
conocerme porque la única manera de
ayudar a los demás era ayudándome a mí
misma
en este viaje de autoconocimiento
encontré un montón de cosas cosas
bonitas cosas no tan bellas y
sentimientos por los que todos los
adolescentes pasamos
justo después de esto cuando tenía 17
años me dijeron que mis riñones habían
dejado de funcionar completamente y que
no había paso atrás con eso me dijeron
que tenía que entrar en la lista de
espera y que bueno tenía que conseguir
un donante de riñón para poder seguir
viviendo
en este momento me di cuenta de que
hablarle al mundo sobre discapacidad y
normalizar esto para los demás no era
suficiente tenía que involucrarme aún
más en el tema
así que comencé a buscar opciones y
comencé plantear diferentes propuestas
así conocí a algunas organizaciones y
conocí a personas que estaban en misma
situación de esta manera llegué a la
asamblea nacional del ecuador conocí la
ley de discapacidades y la ley de
donación de órganos y tejidos' comencé a
organizarme con todas estas personas
porque para mí no era justo que todas
estas esta gente tenga que vivir una
realidad tan dura realidad es que nunca
nadie antes me había querido mostrar yo
tenía que hacer algo para cambiar las
cosas y ese era el momento
fue entonces cuando decidí convertirme
en una activista por los derechos de las
personas discapacitadas porque si yo no
lo hacía nadie más se iba a preocupar
por nosotros
pasó el tiempo y ya me estaba agradando
del colegio tenía 18 años y estaba
entrando a la universidad
un lugar en el que no están tus padres
no están tus amigos que las personas no
les interesa hablar de discapacidad
porque simplemente tienen otra visión de
la vida o porque tienen otras
convicciones y realmente no es un asunto
de ellos
así que para hacer algo de nuevo tenía
que empezar todo otra vez
como no podía quedarme con los brazos
cruzados decidí investigar me di cuenta
que una universidad de aproximadamente
9.000 250 personas existíamos 60
discapacitados no llegamos a ser y el
0,5 por ciento de la universidad
sin embargo necesitábamos demostrarles a
todos que la discapacidad no debe ser
ese fenómeno social al que todo el mundo
le tiene miedo porque no conocen o
porque no saben cómo hablar de él
nosotros en la discapacidad
encontrábamos fortaleza y encontrábamos
un medio para poder cumplir todos
nuestros objetivos y poder realizar
todos nuestros sueños
de esta manera decidimos comenzar a
organizarnos y en medio de toda esta
organización
ocurría otro suceso gigante en mi vida
un día era de noche me llamaron en
realidad era la tercera llamada que yo
recibía me decían que tenía que hacerme
el trasplante de riñón y que por fin
había un donante después de tres años de
haber estado en la lista de espera
realmente esto fue una noticia super
grande para mí yo sabía que iba a
cambiar mi vida por completo que otra
vez iba a poder vivir con mucha más
energía de la que ya tenía y que eso iba
a cambiar por completo todo lo que yo
había vivido antes
sin embargo este cambio en mi vida
conllevaría dejarlo todo otra vez y
empezar las cosas desde cero
es así que tuve que suspender por un
momento mis estudios para dedicarme en
mi salud pero cuando regrese regresé
totalmente recargado
con esta organizarme de nuevo con todos
mis compañeros logramos formar un
movimiento en la universidad que
actualmente incluye personas
discapacidad discapacitadas de la
federación de estudiantes una de esas
personas discapacitadas soy yo
actualmente soy la directora de la
comisión de responsabilidad social de la
federación de mi universidad también me
contacto con las personas trasplantadas
dice que llegará a ser la presidenta de
la asociación ecuatoriana de pacientes
trasplantados donde tratamos de crear
una plataforma para que todas estas
personas tengan la oportunidad de tener
una vida diferente y que las otras
personas no tengan la oportunidad de
discriminar te por una condición
como seres humanos nosotros debemos de
entender que todos nos falta algo
todos tenemos discapacidades
pero debemos utilizar esto para
encontrar nuestro verdadero poder y
hacer de las cosas que nos faltan
nuestra fortaleza
ya han pasado algunos años desde que
todo esto empezó actualmente tengo 22
años
y lo único que puedo decirles
es que crecer duele y en serio duele
mucho pero es lo más bello que nos puede
pasar en la vida
no cambiaría a uno solo de los momentos
de tristeza felicidad emoción e ira
porque realmente me enseñaron de lo que
estoy hecha y todo lo que puedo dar
me enseñaron que en la adversidad yo
podía cumplir todos mis sueños
a mí la discapacidad me abrió las
puertas del mundo y me enseñó las dos
caras del amor
el poder me enseñó que existían
realidades mucho más grandes
afuera de mi metro cuadrado
y mi propia existencia me demostró que
mientras haya vida era mi obligación
como ser humano seguir en movimiento